wait Oh years wait a minute mr. postman
I'm a lion addict and when I heard that
mine was blowing away I said especially
considering all the other horrible
things that happened in 2016 we lost
print now we're losing mind so these are
some of my favorite vines that were
personally picked and hand selected by
me a girl who spends way too much time
on the internet for tending towards when
she's actually watching fun I don't mind
having a daughter that's an activist but
she is picketing me I love this girl
she's gonna be leading the charge for
Rachel maybe she'll be our first female
person okay she's gonna rule the world
that little girl smart what did he do to
get his daughter so mad told her that
she couldn't leave the kitchen so she
ate all her greens and she was like no
I'm fed up oh I caught it her name is
Charlotte and god bless her she created
a very body-positive sort of twerking
style she has a really interesting way
of staying on beat the way her thighs
are hitting sounds like a snap this is
gonna be Jade okay there's a series of
these videos and Kim is going someplace
and the whole time the moms like it okay
there's Air Force Ones it's fresh yes
yeah Brad she's gonna be really mad when
somebody steps on the memo you could
really feel the passion joy it's all
parents are supportive on their kids
first day of school and more kids would
be more hype about school every order
ever so ever it was alive the Barbie was
naked but she only had her shoes on I
need to know so many things
did she just randomly start swearing and
throwing her doll around they need to
watch her
[Music]
what is the light skin say skin it's
like a hole squint thing like oh if I
fail it's a squid day as picture this
boy but Drake the drink effect its rape
effect rihanna all upon him he's not
smiling she's like serious face but with
his eyes he's a motive like this dope
but there i fly away and be at rest
like this dude but they were far away
it's just so much conviction from the
accent to the throw it just sucks it
that's not how you hold it dawg I think
he squeezed the life out of two things
bad day bittersweet man it's like when
you see a photo of the Obamas and they
look so sweet and you're like oh look at
them and you're like oh my god they're
leaving it was a great outlet for so
many young african-american people I
know voice and you know showcase their
talents they deserve like directors gigs
Hollywood internships Tracy thank you
for showing me vines I've never seen
before they're cherish and hold onto
vine don't forgot forgotten we love you
bye holler down
[Music]